nos encontramos en la puerta 42 una de
las múltiples puertas a lo largo del
muro metálico que se levanta en los más
de 3000 kilómetros o en algunas partes
de los más de 3000 kilómetros de la
frontera que comparten México con
Estados Unidos esta puerta 42 está en
Ciudad Juárez y a lo largo del día se
han ido cerrando diferentes puertas Pero
esto todavía se mantiene abiertas y se
puede ver que hay más de un millar de
migrantes Esperando anhelando poder
cruzar del lado estadounidense antes de
que llegue el final del título 42 a la
media noche hora del este sin embargo
también hay unos migrantes desperdigados
que todavía se encuentran del lado de la
reja que no han podido cruzar por los
socavones o por los cuencos que han
hecho anteriormente otros migrantes para
poder estar en esa fila y tener un
posible acceso hacia el Paso Texas de
hecho en el paso el alcalde Oscar Leslie
ha dicho que se están preparando para
lo desconocido con cobijas con comida
con albergues con refugio para por lo
menos 4.000 migrantes que puedan estar
esperando en las siguientes 72 horas al
final del título 42 bueno Muchos
migrantes emprendieron este viaje
asumiendo que el fin del título 42
podría permitir que ellos entraran a
Estados Unidos pero no solo hay nuevas
medidas del gobierno biden sino también
el título ocho en qué consiste y cómo lo
han asumido los migrantes
el título 8 genera temor entre los
migrantes porque para ellos es una
política fronteriza que los puede llegar
a deportar a sus países de origen aquí
hemos hablado por ejemplo con migrantes
venezolanos que han tenido que cruzar
siete países Ellos tienen la solicitudes
de asilo en las cuales dicen que dentro
de su país hay una dictadura que los
intimida que no les da trabajo que no
les da oportunidades pero si incluso con
el título 42 que lo ha deportado muchas
veces y quedan varados en una suerte de
Limbo en México Pues sería muy grave
para ellos que no lograran demostrar Esa
condición de asilo que requieren y que
tuvieran que ser devueltos a su país de
origen de manera que hay temor por eso
mucha gente quiere o bien cruzar hoy
antes de las 12 de la noche hora del
este o bien hacer las cosas al derecho
como se dice por la vía legal a través
de la aplicación que
es por la cual se pide una cita se hace
una entrevista Allí se explican los
motivos donde también hay que tener Pues
un familiar en los Estados Unidos que
pueda llegar a ayudar económicamente a
estas personas y poder cruzar y cumplir
el sueño y reunirse con sus familiares
del otro lado del lado estadounidense